CHARGE MADURO WITH DRUG
TRAFFICKING, PUTTING $15 MILLION
REWARD ON HIM.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
A FIRST AND SECOND FOR THE
SENATE.
FIRST COMMITTEE HEARING SINCE
FLEEING WASHINGTON OVER THE
CORONAVIRUS AND IT’S THE SECOND
TIME AROUND IN THE CONSIDERATION
FOR THE PRESIDENT PICKED TO BE
HIS INTELLIGENCE CHIEF.
CONGRESSIONAL CORRESPONDENT CHAD
PROGRAM IS ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> I CALL THIS HEARING TO ORDER.
THIS HEARING WILL BE A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT.
>> A HEARING CALL TO ORDER FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN TWO MONTHS.
DNI NOMINEE JOHN RATCLIFFE SAT
40 FEET FROM SENATORS AND A
CAVERNOUS HEARING ROOM.
A BOTTLE OF PURELL AT HIS SIDE.
SENATORS USUALLY SQUEEZE ONTO
THE DAIS BUT RICHARD BURR
LIMITED HOW MANY SENATORS COULD
SIT IN THE ROOM AT ONCE.
SENATORS HAD TO STAY IN THEIR
OFFICES UNTIL IT WAS THERE A
TERM TO ASK RATCLIFFE QUESTIONS.
THIS IS A DO OVER FOR RATCLIFF
TO BE THE NATION’S TOP SPY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TAPPED THE
CONGRESSMAN TO SUCCEED RESIGNING
DNI DAN COATS LAST SUMMER BUT
RATCLIFF PULLED OUT AFTER
BIPARTISAN QUESTIONS AROSE ABOUT
HIS QUALIFICATIONS.
>> YOU START OUT BECAUSE EVERY
DEMOCRAT IS AGAINST YOU, MY
CONCERN WAS THERE’S NOT A LOT OF
MARGIN FOR ERROR.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED THAT
HE TOLD RATCLIFFE "HOW MISERABLE
IT WOULD BE FOR HIM AND HIS
FAMILY TO DEAL WITH THESE
PEOPLE."
THE PRESIDENT NEVER NOMINATED
SOMEBODY ELSE.
RATCLIFF EMERGED AS ONE OF
MR. TRUMP’S MOST ARDENT
DEFENDERS DURING IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GAVE RATCLIFF A
MULLIGAN.
DEMOCRATS WONDERED WHAT CHANGED.
>> HE’S A DEEPLY PARTISAN
CHEERLEADER FOR THE PRESIDENT.
A YES-MAN IN EVERY SENSE OF THE
PHRASE, SOMEONE WHO DOESN’T
SPEAK TRUTH TO POWER TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> RATCLIFFE ASSURED SENATORS HE
WOULDN’T TILT INTELLIGENCE TO
ALIGN WITH THE PRESIDENT.
HE PLEDGED INDEPENDENCE, EVEN AS
MR. TRUMP HAS SUGGESTED THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY TRY TO
UNDERMINE HIM.
>> WHETHER YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT, WHETHER YOU’RE
TALKING ABOUT NANCY PELOSI,
MITCH McCONNELL, ANYONE’S
VIEWS ON WHAT THEY WANT THE
INTELLIGENCE TO BE WILL NEVER
IMPACT THE INTELLIGENCE THAT I
DELIVER.
NEVER.
>> RATCLIFFE TESTIFIED HE DIDN’T
THINK THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
HAD RUN AMOK.
HE ALSO SIDESTEPPED A QUESTION
ABOUT INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AND
THE DEEP STATE.
HIS CONFIRMATION VOTE SHOULD
COME BEFORE THE FULL SENATE